voilà déjà un an et demi que patrick
sébastien a quitté les écrans de france
télévisions après les décennies
d'antenne à la tête des programmes
cultes comme le plus grand cabaret du
monde
une absence très longue pour les
nombreux fans de l'animateur remercier
de france 2 en plein succès une chope
ans qu'ils estiment que j'ai plus ma
place
preuve en est avec la présence de
patrick sébastien sur ces 8 samedi
dernier c'est sébastien à la télé c'est
fou qui était diffusée à 21h une
émission dans laquelle l'animateur est
revenu sur les coulisses des programmes
cultes qu'il a créé et dany boon lui
consacre un grand prime quand on est sur
france 2 une émission qui a attiré 700
27 mille téléspectateurs soit 2,9 pour
cent du public une très belle audience
et ce n'est pas tout car en deuxième
partie de soirée était rediffusé un
numéro culte du grand bluff dans lequel
patrick roy michel drucker et jean
pierre foucault été piégé on connaissait
très bien c'est une émission qui là
encore a fait salle comble avec 419
mille téléspectateurs
alors le grand globe ça reste le record
absolu en termes d'audience alors c'est
vrai certes que trois chefs d'al époque
m'enfin c'est mignon christopher moi je
dois faire mon mea culpa j'avais dit que
ça n'ait pas marché ça a marché
benj après on est là mais j'avoue mon
erreur parce que j'ai regardé le
documentaire et c'est vrai que c'était
très bien fait très fouillée et ça
montrait aussi que au delà d'un
animateur c'est aussi un grand artiste
patrick sébastien et donc voilà il
manque énormément à la télé voilà la
preuve de cette audience assez c'est
d'abord un artiste et avait exactement
ils réussirent découvreur de talents à
l'émission c'est dingue donc ils
manquent pour
pluie et manquent pour ce qu'il
apportait aux autres c'est insensé qui
n'est pas une émission mais ça va
revenir vite j'en suis sûr alors dans le
grand bluff
il y avait plein de gens qui ont été
piégées ont là on va alors tout à
l'heure il ya eu focaux mais surtout il
a même réussi à piéger sa propre mère
regardez cet automne
c'est la mode basse batterie sébastien
sont tombés en même temps mais vous
l'aimiez pas c'est une chasse et
benneteau au tour pour eux mêmes nous
tenons prélèvements sur un autre ton se
veut être le meilleur voilà que vous
allez parler sur ce ton là bas elle
madame d'aidé bhutto oui voilà je suis
madame des des boutons et je le resterai
toujours moi ce sens oui monsieur david
m'insulter la team en vous ou sûrement
ne pas se rend pas je me suis jamais
abaissé à faire ça parce que vous êtes
la mer de l'autre qu'on va collaborer
comme ça la fout mal non plus mais non
pas du tout ma faim vous avez commenté
le magasin maman comment il avait réussi
à tirer tout droit et en plus si pièces
de pas de lula depuis les gares à quoi
il est à 10 cm et ne reconnaît pas son
pote regardez
enchères sous les poteaux
je t'aime roccon ok pourquoi j'ai gentil
a commencé général monsieur monsieur je
vous signale que sébastien beaucoup plus
gentil coup sébastien sera mettre en
valeur mais maintenant vous connaissez
bien sébastien goulet s'est très bien
vous êtes sera bien vous assistez à la
chaîne vous connaissez très bien c'est
parce que très bien bonjour jean pierre
foucault
il reste que quatre ans pierre parce que
quelqu'un m'a dit vous y trompez pas ce
que je connais des animateurs et pas
très loin d'ici
quand vous engagez vous à moi très mal
toujours rien dit mais c'est génial pour
ces femmes ça qui fait une grande
tournée aussi par rapport au cabaret
pour ça que pour ses fans a mentionné
qu'il fait une tournée pas pour papoter
voilà qui est extraordinaire c'est que
france télévisions l'a fait partie à
remettre des émissions qui marchent
moins bien et pour enfler rendent la
télévision orpheline de saône et loire